Naomi Naomi Naomi girls yeah your star
is about to explode because mama you
crushed it oh thank you so much
what's your name again Whitney Elizabeth
Houston your performance was captivating
so congratulations thank you it's weird
I know are you having a little flashback
moment yeah I haven't worn those for
like a while yeah a while wrapped last
December yeah that's right close to now
December 14th that is so wild okay walk
me through these this is from the South
Africa performance this is from South
Africa performance I Will Always Love
You This was a concert that is a hot
little this one yeah it's a take one
lead it's not right but it's okay in
that video bro you were looking mad
Fierce than that just like Whitney
herself and I mean this experience is
something it's going to be an awesome
opportunity for fans to get up and close
and personal to these costumes but this
movie the Whitney movie you are the
official face for it you've done all the
preparation the movie is done it just
has to be released yeah it has to be
shared yeah so how do you feel excited
yeah I'm really happy for the fact that
people get to see it you know we worked
really hard we really enjoyed our time
together the class and the crew and it's
like the final missing piece is just
making everyone watch it and see how
they feel about it and reignite their
love for what it is yeah that's good
Whitney was a Powerhouse a a force and
with these films you think it's going to
be amazing yeah but you work so
diligently thank you yeah how much time
did you dedicate to preparing to portray
what it is yeah no I mean I was in prep
for about six months seven months by
myself and and with my dialect coaches I
had three amazing dialect coaches over
an extended amount of time because you
do not have an American accent I do not
no no that's the response of tangible
large Denise woods and Bridget Jackson
are responsible for that I worked with
them an amazing movement coach called
Polly Bennett who was incredible and
that movement coach that worked with
ramion Bohemian rhaps yeah and she
worked with Austin Butler on Elvis and
like she's doing amazing things and she
helped me so much understand the reasons
why Whitney moves and the way she moves
to fill out the performances yeah so
what did the movement coaching and the
training and the guidance that you went
through with her what did that entail
exactly oh God I mean it was me it was
me in East London for a lot of the time
in a dance studio like walking around
pretending to be Whitney Houston yeah
and like is it much different from your
walk yeah probably yeah
yeah I'll slouchy girl and Whitney was
very poised it was studying the songs
and and her history and what she was
like as a child and all of this
beautiful imaginary work that me as an
actor I just like live for so it was
very rich preparation time and then I
got to Boston and then we started
playing with that and playing with the
costumes and the singing and I was in
the studio you know attempting to sing
is the songs and yeah and it was it was
an amazing experience it really pushed
me to my outer limits and I'm so happy
that I got to do it I mean Naomi down to
her lip movements down to the arms
directing the band behind her I was like
oh
child
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
did you ever notice yourself in real
life going whoa that was a little too
Whitney bring it back in oh my God like
all the time yeah actually like I I've
been saying it like I I would be like
talking to my family in my accent my own
accent but I would have like the same
syncopation as Whitney sometimes when I
was talking because they you know your
life starts to blend together you're
doing it for so long I was just like one
and the same it was it was a crazy time
almost equally as fascinating to me you
star in this biopic but you are so
executive produce
so what is the significance of both of
those roles to you especially when
you've got folks on board from Whitney's
family yeah Clive Davis who are really
for the first time giving their official
step of approval yeah it was huge I mean
that that came as a beautiful surprise I
appreciate them for listening to my
creativity and and having an input and
that's where it really came from I was
talking about the story and talking
about my ideas around the film and then
like halfway through our process they
were like hey do you want to you know
have an EP credit and I was like oh my
God yes please for me it's like it's a
sign that they really loved what I was
adding to it as well as just an actor as
a creative and you know it's helpful for
me because that's what I want to do in
the future I want to be able to provide
storytelling platforms for more people
so it's just a step closer to what I
want to be able to do myself I love the
casting of Stanley too she is flat Davis
genius the two of y'all Batman
he is just and he became a hot commodity
even more so during the pandemic I know
we were talked about that because I
think with the cocktails and stuff he's
so cool we would sit and like I would
just I don't know how to cook very well
um but I would I would just listen to
him tell me about like food that he
likes and that was purely just joyful
and he's a beautiful man and so so
talented but like you know we knew that
yeah and stabbed me well speaking of
beauty I feel like something maybe fan
fans aren't as well aware of it's a
relationship Whitney had with Robin
Crawford so we see that relationship
being explored right after that yes film
for you and if that's so what was most
important to you in your approach and
tackling this relationship and also that
fine line between confidante and lover
between the two yeah um me and official
like we talked about it and really the
basis of their relationship is a
friendship it's love it's a strong
strong bond we just wanted to show how
much they like sparked off of each other
and loved each other and joked around
and were able to achieve so much because
of the support they had of each other
and especially Robin supporting Whitney
it's beautiful and I think we can all
look at moments in our lives where we've
had friends or have friends like that
and what they had was was gorgeous and
we just wanted to represent it properly
and give it a nod to that I love that
they [ __ ]
he really loves me
my dream
seeing what I want to sing be how I want
to be
of course we know Whitney is the voice
someone whose dream was to sing what
would you say is your dream kind of
doing it right now yeah so executive
producing starring being a bad mama jama
that you are
you're a truth right after this ah yeah
I mean that's the hope it's the hope to
just keep creating yeah and keep having
fun and keep meeting new people and
hopefully making people happy bringing
light into people's life in this small
way
um
yeah you are this is the ultimate way to
wrap up 2022 it's a little present to
all of us as well and I hope are you
ready for all the praise that your name
and your talent is going to be garnering
as we end 2022 going into award season
I'm just saying it is going to happen
like are you ready no probably not
you're ready girl start moving over some
things on the mantle get a shelf because
I can see it now that's you thank you
but we'll put a nomination for the role
or for the film in and of itself what
would that mean oh my gosh you know I
think this whole experience has been
such a beautiful one that releasing it
is an added a beautiful experience being
able to share with people is an added
experience the everything else you know
is icing compared to the things that
I've learned and the people that I've
met and that's to me the most important
thing
um so anything other than that you're
very humble that would be the cherry on
time oh yeah it's probably shiny
something yeah
[Music]